>>> YOU JUST TAPPED INTO "THE
GROUP CHAT" LIVE.
I'M GREG IVORY AND FILLING IN IS
THE MAN, THE MYTH, THE LEGEND,
THE MAN BEHIND THE CURTAIN, THE
MAN WHO OVERSEES ALL OF BR
BETTING SOCIAL, CHANNEL SOCIAL
PLATFORMS, WHATEVER YOU WANT TO
CALL IT, MY MAN SAM RICHMOND.
SAM, WE ALL KNOW YOU ARE THE
SHARP OF THE DEPARTMENT.
WHAT IS YOUR SECRET, MY FRIEND?
>> I DON'T KNOW IF I AM, GREG.
BUT I WANT TO SAY TWO THINGS.
ONE, I AM HONORED TO BE HERE
HOSTING THE SHOW WITH YOU.
AND, TWO, THIS COMES AT A
PERFECT TIME FOR ME BECAUSE I
SUFFERED THE WORST COLLEGE
BASKETBALL BEAT YESTERDAY WITH
ALABAMA MINUS THREE AND A HALF.
I'M SURE PEOPLE WHO ADDED IT IN
THE COMMENTS KNOW THE PAIN AND
HURT I'M GOING RIGHT NOW.
IT IS THE PERFECT TIME FOR ME TO
LOCK IN ON NBA.
I'M DONE WITH COLLEGE
BASKETBALL.
WHAT A BETTER WAY TO DO THAT
THAN WINNING SOME BETS TONIGHT.
LET'S BE GREAT.
>> LET'S BE GREAT, IN FACT.
AS ALWAYS, WE'RE HERE GIVING OUT
FIVES, GIVING OUT LOCKS, GIVING
OUT JERSEYS.
SO GET IN THE COMMENTS.
I NEED GIFs, I NEED EMOJIS, AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY, I NEED WINNERS
ONLY, PLEASE, SAM.
IN FACT, I'M GOING TO GIVE OUT A
JERSEY RIGHT NOW.
SO I'M ON THE HANDY DANDY PHONE
LOOKING FOR TAKES.
I SEE MAX IN THE COMMENTS.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
ROCKING WITH D. BOOK.
I ALSO SEE -- I ALSO SEE -- HOLD
ON.
MICHAEL.
MICHAEL BOLAN IS IN THE
COMMENTS.
JAKE THE SNAKE IS IN THE
HERE WE GO.
ODIN SAYS BOOKER IS HOT.
I THINK D. BOOK WILL HAVE THE
GAME HIGH.
SO YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH THE
JERSEY.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
SAM, ARE YOU READY TO GET THE
SHOW LIKE OFFICIALLY STARTED,
BROTHER?
>> LET'S DO IT.
I'M REALLY EXCITED, MAN.
>> ALL RIGHT, EVERYBODY.
IT IS TNT BASKETBALL THURSDAY.
FANDUEL IS BOOSTING THE THREE BY
TWO IN BOTH GAMES TONIGHT.
THE QUESTION IS WILL THERE BE
TWO THREE-POINTERS IN THE FIRST
THREE MINUTES OF THE GAME?
LAST WEEK THE THREE BY TWO CASH
IN THE PORTLAND/DENVER GAME.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> CROWD ON THEIR FEET.
>> THERE IT IS IN THE CORNER.
NASSIR LITTLE KNOCKS IT DOWN.
AND, IN FACT, SAM, NASSIR LITTLE
KNOCKED BOTH OF THESE DOWN FOR
US, CASHING THE THREE BY TWO
EARLY.
THIS ONE WASN'T A SWEATER, SAM.
THIS ONE YOU DIDN'T HAVE TO
REALLY SWEAT THIS ONE.
THIS ONE WAS EASY.
BUT TODAY WE ASKED YOU ON
TWITTER, ACTUALLY.
MY MAN SAM PROBABLY TWEETED THIS
HIMSELF.
HE ASKED YOU WHICH THREE BY TWO
WILL CASH TONIGHT?
IS IT THE SUNS TAKING ON THE
MAVS?
OR IS IT THE WARRIORS TAKING ON
THE PACERS?
SAM, HERE ARE THE RESULTS.
HERE ARE THE RESULTS.
THERE THEY ARE.
SAM, THIS ONE IS REALLY, REALLY
CLOSE.
I NEED EVERYBODY TO GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND TELL US WHICH THREE
BY TWO IS A LOCK.
BUT, SAM, TALK TO US.
TALK TO THE PEOPLE.
WHICH ONE IS YOUR FAVORITE?
>> YEAH.
I'M SURPRISED THIS IS SO CLOSE.
ONE STANDS OUT TO ME VERY MUCH
SO, AND THAT IS WARRIORS/PACERS.
I LOVE THIS THREE BY TWO.
NOW, I WILL PROVIDE SOME GROUND
BREAKING ANALYSIS.
YOU CANNOT GET THIS ANYWHERE
ELSE.
THE WARRIORS SHOOT A LOT OF
THREE-POINTERS.
I THINK EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT.
THEY'RE THIRD IN THE LEAGUE
WHERE THE PACERS ARE 23rd IN
DEFENDING THE THREE-POINT LINE
AND THE WARRIORS YOU EXPECT THE
NUMBERS TO GO UP NOW THAT KLAY
IS BACK.
SO GO AGAINST A TEAM THAT
STRUGGLES AGAINST THE LINE, I
REALLY LIKE THAT.
THE PACERS ARE THE MIDDLE OF THE
BACK THEMSELVES, SO MAYBE THEY
WILL SNEAK ONE IN FOR YOU AS
WELL.
I LIKE STEPH AND KLAY TO SNEAK
THIS IN FOR US AS WELL.
>> YEAH.
TRUSTING THE SPLASH BROTHERS.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS RIGHT NOW,
SAM.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS LOOKING FOR
TAKES.
I GOT MON2300AP SAYS PACERS AND
WARRIORS.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I GOT -- I GOT SNOOPY.
SNOOPY IS IN THE COMMENTS 2153
INDIANA/GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
YOU TWO ARE WALKING AWAY WITH
HOODIES.
WE ARE RIDING WITH YOU, BROTHER.
WE ARE ALL RIDING AS A FAMILY,
THE WARRIORS AND THE PACERS.
SO LET'S ALL GET RICH.
NOW MOVING ON, SAM.
TODAY WE ASKED YOU IN THE APP:
WHO WILL SCORE MORE POINTS?
IS IT LUKA DONCIC, OR IS IT
DEVIN BOOKER?
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND TELL US
WHAT YOU THINK.
AT THE END OF THE GAME, ONE
RANDOM PERSON WILL GUESS
CORRECTLY AND HOOK YOU UP WITH A
JERSEY.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE CURRENT
ODDS.
SAM, WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> YEAH.
I REALLY LIKE BOOKER OVER LUKA
TONIGHT.
BOOKER HAS BEEN GOING CRAZY
LATELY.
HE'S HIT OVER 26.5.
LUKA ON THE OTHER SIDE ONLY HIT
THIS TWICE.
THERE IS ALSO A LITTLE SNEAKY
FACTOR HERE THAT I LIKE A LOT.
YOU LOOK AT THIS AND YOU SEE
THAT LUKA SCORED 40 POINTS
YESTERDAY.
YOU MIGHT SAY, OH, THIS IS GOING
TO CONTINUE.
HE WILL DO IT AGAIN.
BUT THIS IS THE SECOND NIGHT OF
A BACK-TO-BACK.
HE PLAYED THE MOST MINUTES OF
ANY GAME HE PLAYED ALL SEASON.
HE SCORED 40 POINTS.
HE LEFT IT ALL ON THE COURT
YESTERDAY.
ASKING HIM TO DO THAT AGAIN
TODAY AGAINST A REALLY GOOD SUNS
TEAM.
I KNOW WHAT TO EXPECT.
HE WILL BE SHORT ON JUMPERS
TONIGHT WHEN HE DOES THAT
STEPBACK THREE.
MAYBE THE WAY I'M PICKING IN
THIS GAME.
BUT I THINK LUKA GASES OUT A
LITTLE BIT, AND HE GOES UNDER
TONIGHT.
SO I LIKE BOOK.
>> I LIKE THAT.
I LIKE THAT A LOT, SAM.
I'M GOING WITH D. BOOK OVER
TONIGHT.
I'M GOING WITH D. BOOK OVER.
HE SCORED 30 PLUS IN HIS LAST
THREE GAMES.
HE'S BEEN ON A TEAR, AND THE
SUNS, THEY NEED THIS GAME IN
DALLAS.
THE WARRIORS ARE ON THE HOME
STAND RIGHT NOW WHERE THEY'RE
LOOKING TO GATHER WINS.
THE SUNS NEED TO CONTINUE
WINNING IN ORDER TO STAY THE ONE
SEED IN THE WEST.
SO I CAN SEE THEM GRABBING THIS
ONE TODAY IN DALLAS.
SO IN ORDER FOR THEM TO WIN, I
NEED MY GUY D. BOOK TO SCORE.
I CAN SEE HIM GOING OVER 26.5
POINTS, SAM.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS.
I AM IN THE COMMENTS BECAUSE I
WANT TO KNOW WHAT THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
LUKA IS DOING IT.
SO, SAM, I THINK THEY'RE FADING
YOU.
I THINK THEY'RE SAYING LUKA IS
GOING TO OUTSCORE BY GUY DEVIN
BOOKER TONIGHT.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU CHAMP CHEESE.
I'M BACK IN THE COMMENTS, AND I
SEE BR BETTING.
BR BETTING SAYS LUKA IS WATCHING
SAM FADE HIM.
BR BETTING IS IN THE COMMENTS,
SAM.
OFFICIALLY RONALD SAYS D. BOOK.
HAVE A D. BOOK GIF IN THERE.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU. YOU ARE
WALKING AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
REMEMBER AFTER THE GAME.
REMEMBER AFTER THE GAME, WE WILL
HIT UP ONE PERSON AND HOOK YOU
UP WITH A JERSEY.
SO FOLLOW US ON SOCIALS.
SAM, IT'S MY FAVORITE PART.
IT'S MY FAVORITE PART OF THE
SHOW.
LET'S TALK MAJOR MARKETS.
MONEY MARKETS AGAINST THE
SPREADS AND POINT TOTALS FOR
TONIGHT'S GAME.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE ODDS.
SAM, WHAT DO YOU SEE HERE?
AND WHAT DO YOU LIKE?
>> YEAH.
SO I'M JUST GOING TO KEEP UP MY
SUNS LOVE.
I LIKE THEM TONIGHT.
THE MINUS 142 MONEY LINE.
MONEY LINE SEEMS PRETTY CHEAP TO
ME.
LITTLE STAT FOR YOU, GREG.
THE SUNS ARE 14-2 STRAIGHT UP AS
ROAD FAVORITES THIS SEASON.
THEY'RE AN NBA BEST 11-6.
ST
SO THEY HAVE BEEN REALLY GOOD AT
THIS SPOT.
I'M SORRY TO DISAPPOINT THAT
COMMENT.
MAYBE I WILL BE WRONG.
BUT I THINK THE BACK-TO-BACK
MATTERS.
I THINK HE LEFT IT ALL OUT THERE
LAST NIGHT.
IT IS A LOT TO ASK HIM TO DO
THAT AGAIN AGAINST A GOOD TEAM.
I THINK THE SUNS ARE A BETTER
TEAM.
I LOVE PHOENIX TONIGHT.
>> YEAH, SAM.
I'M LOOKING IN THE COMMENTS,
MAN.
I'M LOOKING IN THE COMMENTS, AND
I'M JUST GOING TO GO THROUGH
THEM GIVING OUT HOODIES.
LUKA HAVING 30.
OH, MY.
23, SHOUTS OUT TO YOU.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
NO, BRO.
LUKA GOING FOR 3.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
I LIKE THE STATS, SAM.
HE'S ROCKING WITH YOUR STATS,
SAM.
SHOUTS OUT TO YOU.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
SAM, YOU ARE WALKING WITH THE
SUNS MONEY LINE.
I ALSO WANT TO TALK
WARRIORS/PACERS HERE.
I DO THINK THE WARRIORS -- THAT
CAN BE A ROUTE.
THAT CAN BE A ROUTE.
HEARD NO SABONIS TONIGHT.
IT CAN BE A ROUTE IN SAN
FRANCISCO TONIGHT.
BUT MY THING IS WHEN THE
WARRIORS PUT IN THOSE RESERVES,
ARE THEY GOING TO CONTINUE
SCORING OR ARE THEY GOING TO
CRUMBLE TOWARDS THE END OF THE
GAME?
BUT I FEEL CONFIDENT.
I DO FEEL CONFIDENT IN THE SUNS
GETTING A WIN TONIGHT.
I MENTIONED IT EARLIER IN THE
SHOW WHEN I WAS TALKING ABOUT D.
BOOKER.
I CAN SEE THEM GOING TO DALLAS
TODAY AND GETTING THIS WIN.
THEY NEED TO STACK UP SOME WINS.
FEBRUARY IS COMING.
THIS IS USUALLY AFTER THE ALL
STAR BREAK IS WHEN TEAMS START
TURNING IT ON.
I THINK PHOENIX IS TRYING TO DO
THIS EARLY BECAUSE THEY KNOW THE
GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS ARE
COMING, AND THE ONE SEED IS
VERY, VERY, VERY IMPORTANT.
SO I'M ROCKING WITH THE SUNS.
LET'S MOVE ON.
WE TALKED MAJOR MARKETS, SAM.
NOW LET'S TALK PLAYER PROPS.
IT'S TIME FOR LOCK OR NOT.
I'M GOING TO PUT UP A PROP, AND
I NEED ALL OF YOU IN THE
COMMENTS TO GET IN THE COMMENTS
AND TELL US IF IT'S A -- IF IT'S
A LOCK OR IT'S NOT.
SAM, ARE YOU READY?
>> LET'S GO.
I'M EXCITED, MAN.
>> LET'S GET RIGHT TO IT.
LET'S GET RIGHT TO IT.
PROP OR NOT?
FIRST UP, FIRST UP WE HAVE KLAY
THOMPSON TO HAVE OVER 13.5
POINTS, SAM, AND SITTING AT
MINUS 112.
TALK TO ME.
TALK TO THE PEOPLE.
DO YOU LIKE THIS ONE?
IS THIS A LOCK OR NOT?
>> FIRST I JUST WANT TO SAY WE
HAVE AGREED ON EVERY PICK SO
FAR.
TALKING ABOUT VIBES, IT IS HARD
TO DO BETTER THAN THAT.
GOOD VIBES AS ALWAYS.
I LIKE THIS OVER FOR KLAY.
AGAIN, WE TALKED ABOUT PACERS
NOT VERY GOOD DEFENDING THE
THREE.
KLAY THAT OBVIOUSLY HELPS A GUY
OUT.
I THINK THIS IS A ROUTE.
I THINK THE WARRIORS GET UP
EARLY.
THIS IS A GOOD GAME FOR THE
WARRIORS TO GET KLAY GOING
AGAINST COMPETITION.
THEY WERE MISSING THREE OR FOUR
OF THEIR BEST PLAYERS.
I THINK WE HAVE SEEN SINCE KLAY
HAS BEEN BACK, HE HAS NOT BEEN
AFRAID TO SHOOT THE BALL.
I THINK HE WILL GO MORE THAN THE
20-POINT RANGE, WHICH I THINK HE
HAD IN THE LAST GAME, SO I AM
TAKING THE OVER HERE.
>> SAM, I'M RIGHT THERE WITH
YOU.
KLAY HAD 21 IN HIS LAST GAME.
I THINK KLAY GETS IN THE GROOVE
ON THE HOME STAND.
THE WARRIORS ARE ON A SEVEN-GAME
HOME STAND.
I THINK HE GETS IN THE GROOVE
HERE.
HE LOVES PLAYING IN FRONT OF
THAT BAY AREA CROWD.
YOU HAVE BEEN THERE.
I HAVE BEEN THERE.
WE KNOW HE'S GOING TO PUT UP THE
SHOTS.
YOU JUST MENTIONED THAT.
SO I LOVE PUTTING MY MONEY ON
KLAY THOMPSON HERE SITTING AT
MINUS 112.
GIVE ME THE OVER.
LET'S MOVE ON SAM.
ACTUALLY BEFORE WE MOVE ON, I'M
IN THE COMMENTS.
I GOT TO GIVE AWAY ANOTHER
HOODIE.
GOT TO SEE IF THEY'RE RIDING
WITH US.
OH, I GOT THE LOCK TALK IN THE
COMMENTS.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU, BROTHER.
AUSTIN MARCH TELL, SAM.
HE SAYS KLAY IS GOING FOR 20.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
YOU TOO ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
SAM, LET'S MOVE ON STEPH CURRY.
STEPH CURRY IS SITTING AT PLUS
136.
TALK TO THE PEOPLE, SAM.
TALK TO ME.
DO YOU LIKE THIS ONE?
IS THIS IS LOCK OR IS IT NOT?
>> THIS IS A TOUGH ONE FOR ME.
I'M A HUGE STEP GUY.
I EVEN FEEL DIRTY ABOUT SAYING
THIS IN FRONT OF YOU BECAUSE I
KNOW YOU LOVE STEPH.
EVERYONE LOVES STEPH.
I CAN'T TAKE THE OVER HERE.
HE'S ONLY HIT OVER FIVE THREES
ONCE THIS ENTIRE MONTH.
HIS SCORING HAS ALSO BEEN DOWN
IN GENERAL SINCE KLAY HAS CAME
BACK.
I THINK HE'S SCORED UNDER 20
POINTS IN THREE STRAIGHT.
BUT I THINK THE BIG FACTOR HERE
FOR ME IS I EXPECT THIS GAME TO
BE A BLOW-OUT.
THE PACERS WILL BE MISSING SOME
OF THEIR KEY GUYS.
YOU WILL PROBABLY HAVE THE
WARRIORS UP 20, 25 POINTS.
IF STEPH HITS, YOU ARE MISSING
OUT ON 8 MINUTES OF HIM GETTING
THREES.
SO I CAN'T GET THERE.
I WOULD TAKE THE UNDER HERE.
>> THAT'S FACTS.
THAT IS A FACT, SAM.
YOU MAKE GREAT POINTS.
MY GUY, STEPH, HASN'T DONE THIS
SINCE NEW YEAR'S.
YOU KNOW HOW MUCH I LOVE ROCKING
WITH STEPH CURRY.
BUT HONESTLY I PROBABLY WOULDN'T
PUT MY MONEY ON THIS, SAM.
YOU'RE TAKING ON THE PACERS.
THIS ONE MIGHT BE A BLOW-OUT.
STEPH MIGHT GET HOT EARLY.
IF YOU HAVE GOT THE EARLY,
SPRINKLE IT.
IF YOU ARE UP ON THE WEEK,
SPRINKLE SOMETHING ON IT.
IT MAY HIT, MAYBE NOT HIT.
BUT I'M NOT PUTTING MY MONEY ON
IT.
ACTUALLY, BEFORE WE MOVE ON, I
GOT TO TAP INTO THE COMMENTS,
MAN.
I GOT TO TAP INTO THE COMMENTS
AND SEE WHAT THEY ARE TALKING
ABOUT.
I GOT 8807 SAYS, HEY, GREG.
I'M HERE.
HI.
HOW ARE YOU DOING?
AND THEN THEY ALSO SAID LUKA.
LUKA IS HAVING MORE POINTS THAN
D. BOOK.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOO
HOODIE.
SAM, NEXT UP.
NEXT UP WE HAVE KEVON LOONEY.
MY GUY KEVON LOONEY TO HAVE 10
OR MORE REBOUNDS SITTING AT PLUS
116, SAM.
TALK TO ME.
TALK TO THE PEOPLE.
DO YOU LIKE THIS ONE OR DO YOU
NOT LIKE THIS ONE?
>> YEAH.
THIS IS AN INTERESTING ONE TO ME
BECAUSE IF YOU LOOK AT HIS
SEASON LONG NUMBERS, HE DOES NOT
AVERAGE 10 REBOUNDS A GAME.
BUT SINCE DRAYMOND HAS BEEN OUT,
HE'S HIT DOUBLE DIGIT REBOUNDS.
WE TALKED ABOUT IT.
THE PACERS ARE PUTTING OUT WHAT
I LIKE TO CALL A POVERTY LINEUP.
I EXPECT THEM TO MISS A LOT OF
SHOTS.
I EXPECT LOONEY TO GRAB THEM AND
CLEAN THEM UP.
WE'RE SPREADING GOOD WORDS,
VIBES.
LET'S TAKE PLUS FOR LOONEY.
>> YEAH.
I'M RIGHT HERE WITH YOU.
LOONEY HAS BEEN PICKING UP THE
SLACK SINCE THERE'S BEEN NO
DRAYMOND.
HE'S GONE 10 OR PLUS REBOUNDS.
NO SABONIS FOR THE PACERS.
I'M GOING TO ROCK WITH THE OVER
AS WELL HERE, SAM.
LOOK FOR LOONEY TO BE CRASHING
THE BOARDS, GRABBING THOSE
BOARDS DOWN THERE IN THIS
WARRIORS ROUTE, YOU KNOW?
RESERVES IN FOR THE PACERS.
I'M ROCKING WITH MY GUY LOONEY.
I WANT TO SEE WHAT YOU GUYS ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
I SEE HEY ARNOLD IN THE
COMMENTS.
I ALSO SEE LARRY HALL OF FAME
SAYS SUNS MONEY LINE.
LET'S GET THIS MONEY.
RICH DUBS, HERE WE GO.
LIKE THE BET FOR LOONEY, GUYS.
HE LIKES IT A LOT.
SNOOPY ALSO SAYS IT'S A LOCK
WITHOUT DRAYMOND IN THE GAME.
13 REBOUNDS FOR LOONEY.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU GUYS.
YOU GUYS ARE WALKING AWAY WITH
HOODIES.
SAM, IT'S TIME TO BUILD.
IT'S YOUR FAVORITE PART OF THE
SHOW, SAM.
IT'S TIME TO BUILD THE BR
BETTING CUSTOM SAME GAME PARLAY
WHICH YOU CAN RIDE WITH US ON
FANDUEL.
AND SPEAKING OF LAST WEEK, WE
SHOWED YOU THREE FRIENDS WHO
TURNED ONE -- NO.
THEY TURNED 50 CENTS INTO
$130,000 ON A FIRST BASKET
PARLAY.
THIS WEEK WE GOT ANOTHER ONE FOR
YOU GUYS.
MY GUY MICAH TURNED 32 CENTS
INTO $14,400 ON THE FIRST BASKET
PARLAY.
THERE IT IS RIGHT THERE, SAM.
DO YOU -- LIKE BE HONEST WITH
ME, SAM.
WE CALL YOU THE SHARP OF THE
DEPARTMENT.
DO YOU HONESTLY -- DO YOU MAKE
THESE ON YOUR OFF TIME?
>> I DON'T.
BUT LIKE THE MORE I SEE THESE,
THE MORE I'M LIKE -- I WANT TO
GET IN.
LORD, I HAVE SEEN WHAT WE DO FOR
OTHERS.
SEND THOSE GOOD VIBES MY WAY.
IT IS SO IMPRESSIVE.
I DON'T KNOW HOW PEOPLE COME UP
WITH THIS LIKE ADDING PORZINGIS
AND HOLMES.
IT IS JUST CRAZY, BUT GOOD FOR
THOSE PEOPLE, MAN.
I LOVE TO SEE THE COMMUNITY WIN.
>> YES, I LOVE TO SEE THE
COMMUNITY WIN.
LIKE SAM SAID, LORD, PLEASE,
SEND THOSE VIBES MY WAY.
WE NEED THOSE VIBES BECAUSE I'M
GOING TO GIVE OUT OUR PARLAY.
I NEED EVERYBODY TO GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND TELL ME WHAT THEY
THINK.
WHICH LEGS ARE LOCKS, WHICH LEGS
ARE NOT.
AND TONIGHT WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
SUNS/MAVERICKS GAME.
AND FIRST WE ARE STARTING OFF
WITH MY MAN CHRIS PAUL.
8 OR MORE ASSISTS.
SAM, TALK TO ME.
TALK TO THE PEOPLE.
DO YOU LIKE THIS LEG OR DO YOU
NOT?
>> I LOVE IT.
HE AVERAGES 10 PER GAME.
HE AVERAGED 11 PER MONTH.
HE'S THE POINT GUY.
HE'S NOT GOING TO LEAVE THE GAME
WITHOUT 8 ASSISTS.
THAT'S AN EASY LEG IN MY MIND.
>> SAM SAYS THIS ONE IS EASY.
LET'S MOVE ON.
LET'S TALK ABOUT LUKA DONCIC
SITTING AT 10 OR MORE REBOUNDS.
SAM, TALK TO ME.
TALK TO THE PEOPLE.
DO YOU LIKE THIS ONE?
>> I LIKE THIS ONE ESPECIALLY
WHERE THE VALUE CAME IN FOR THE
PARLAY.
THIS TURNED THIS FROM A PLUS 200
SMALL HIT TO A POTENTIAL PLUS
500 HIT.
SURE, LUKA DOESN'T AVERAGE 10
REBOUNDS FOR THE SEASON.
BUT IN JANUARY HE'S AVERAGING 11
PER GAME.
HE'S HIT 10 REBOUNDS IN 5 OF HIS
LAST 6 GAMES AND THE ONLY ONE HE
DIDN'T GET IS 9 REBOUNDS.
TO GET THIS WITH EVEN ODDS WITH
HOW MUCH WORK HE'S DOING ON THE
GLASS RIGHT NOW, I LOVE THIS.
I THINK IT IS A GREAT ADDITION
TO THE PARLAY.
>> SAM LIKES IT.
I LIKE IT AS WELL.
WE GOT DEVIN BOOKER.
TWO OR MORE THREE-POINTERS MADE
IN TONIGHT'S BALL GAME.
SAM, TALK TO ME.
DO YOU LIKE THIS ONE OR DO YOU
NOT?
>> YEAH.
I HATE TO KEEP SAYING THE SAME
THING.
BUT I LOVE THIS.
I THINK ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU LOOK
AT BOOKER, HE'S TAKING 13 THREES
IN TWO OF HIS LAST THREE GAMES.
HE'S PUT IT UP FROM BEYOND THE
ARK.
HE'S AVERAGING THREE PER GAME
THIS MONTH.
TO ONLY NEED TWO IT FEELS VERY
EASY, WHICH IT IS NEVER EASY TO
HIT A PARLAY.
BUT I LOVE THE VALUE HERE.
TWO THREES FROM DEVEN?
LOVE IT.
>> THE MAN BEHIND THE CURTAIN IS
WHAT WE CALL HIM.
SAM, I'M STARTING TO THINK YOU
HAD YOUR HANDS ON MAKING THIS
PAR
PARLAY.
LET'S MOVE ON.
MYKAEL BRIDGES.
SAM, TALK TO ME, DO YOU LIKE
THIS ONE?
>> YEAH, I LIKE IT.
AGAIN, YOU'RE PEELING BACK THE
CURTAIN.
I DID HAVE A HAND IN MAKING THIS
PARLAY, SO I AM BIASSED.
YEAH.
HE AVERAGED 12 A GAME.
HE'S BEEN SCORING AGAIN WELL
THIS MONTH.
WE NEED A LITTLE BIT LESS THAN
HIS AVERAGE.
I THINK THE SUNS PLAY REALLY
WELL WITH HIM TONIGHT.
LET'S RIDE WITH HIM.
>> SAM, WE ARE RIDING, BROTHER.
WE ARE RIDING.
LET'S PUT UP THE TICKET SO WE
CAN SEE THE ODDS AND THE TOTALS
HERE.
YOU GUYS PUT $100 DOWN, YOU WILL
BE WALKING AWAY WITH $532.71
RIGHT THERE.
SAM, BEFORE I GET IN THE
COMMENTS, WHAT ARE YOU GRADING
THE PARLAY.
>> WELL, IT FEELS WEIRD TO GRADE
SOMETHING I BUILT, SO I'M GOING
TO GIVE IT AN A PLUS.
THIS IS THE GREATEST PARLAY EVER
BUILT.
A PLUS HERE.
>> SAM, I AM FEELING THE VIBES,
BROTHER.
I AM FEELING THE VIBES.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS, THOUGH.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS.
SAM IS GIVING US GOOD VIBES.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS GIVING US
GOOD VIBES.
JERRY SAYS BRIDGES POINTS IS A
BIG GAMBLE.
BUT GUESS WHAT?
I'M SENDING YOU A HOODIE.
THAT'S NOT A GAMBLE.
BUT WE TAKE CHANCES HERE.
THAT'S WHAT WE DO.
WE TAKE CHANCES AND WE TAKE OUR
GAMBLES.
SO I GOT THE SPICY ANGELS.
THE SPICY ANGEL ALSO SAYS PASS
ON BRIDGES REBOUNDS.
SAM, I DON'T THINK YOU HAVE
BRIDGES REBOUNDS.
>> WE DID NOT.
THAT'S A TOUGH LOOK.
>> YEAH.
GIVING AWAY A JERSEY HERE, SAM.
I GOT JULIO HERNANDEZ.
FEEL LIKE I GAVE THEM A JERSEY
ALREADY BEFORE, BUT I'LL GIVE
THEM ANOTHER ONE.
WELCOME, SAM, AND WHAT'S UP,
GREG.
ANY TIME WE TALK ABOUT CP-3
ASSISTS, IT'S A LOCK.
BOOK WILL HIT OVER FIVE THREES.
HE'S ON FIRE AND MAKING A CASE
FOR NOT ONLY ALL STAR BUT MVP.
BRIDGES IS A LOCK FOR 10 POINTS.
HE AVERAGES DOUBLE FIGURES AND
WILL BRING IT IN TONIGHT.
I'M RIDING WITH THIS PARLAY,
SAM.
JULIO HERNANDEZ LOVES YOUR
PARLAY.
JULIO, THANK YOU FOR THAT TAKE.
THOSE TYPE OF TAKES GETS
JERSEYS, AND THAT'S WHAT YOU ARE
WALKING AWAY WITH.
SAM, WE TALKED.
I MEAN, WE HAVE YOU HERE.
WE HAVE YOU HERE.
IT IS SUCH AN HONOR AND A
PLEASURE FOR YOU TO BE HERE ON
THE SHOW TODAY.
SAM, YOU LOVE TALKING FUTURES,
SO WE'RE GOING TO TALK MVP
ROOKIE OF THE YEAR AND ODDS TO
WIN IT ALL.
WE'RE KICKING IT OFF WITH MVP,
SAM.
LET'S PULL UP THE LATEST ODDS.
WHAT IS YOUR FAVORITE PLAY HERE,
SAM?
>> YEAH.
AGAIN, THIS IS TOUGH FOR ME
BECAUSE I'M SUCH A STEPH GUY.
GRAB THE FAVORITE.
GRAB STEPH AT PLUS 180.
BUT THE NUMBER WORRIES ME.
HE'S BEEN SCORING LESS.
I THINK HE'S LOST A LITTLE BIT
OF CONTROL OF THE NARRATIVE.
HE HAD IT REALLY STRONG EARLIER
IN THE SEASON.
THEN HE WENT THROUGH A SLUMP.
I EXPECT HIM TO CONTINUE TO BE
GREAT BUT THE NUMBER IS A LITTLE
OUT OF WHACK FOR ME.
I HAVE MONEY ON ONE OF THESE
GUYS, JOHN MORANT.
HE'S NOW 14-1.
I LOVE MORANT, ESPECIALLY IF THE
GRIZZLIES CAN JUMP UP AND GET A
TWO OR THREE SEED.
IT'S GOING TO BE HARD TO NOT
GIVE HIM A SERIOUS LOOK.
BUT MY FAVORITE NUMBER ON THE
BOARD RIGHT NOW IS GIANNIS
ANTETOKOUNMPO.
I THINK HE'S AROUND PLUS 360.
I THINK THE THING I LOVE MOST
ABOUT THIS IS THE BUCKS ARE ONLY
NUMBER TWO OUT OF THE EAST.
IF HE'S ABLE TO GET THEM THERE
AGAIN PUTTING UP JUST THE INSAME
NUMBERS, IT'S REALLY GOING TO BE
HARD NOT TO GIVE HIM THAT AWARD.
AGAIN, I THINK ESPECIALLY AFTER
HIM WINNING THE TITLE, I THINK
PEOPLE ARE COMFORTABLE CALLING
HIM THE BEST PLAYER IN THE
LEAGUE AGAIN.
WHETHER OR NOT THAT'S TRUE, I
THINK THE NARRATIVE SETS UP FOR
HIM TO MAKE A RUNNING TICKET.
I LIKE GIANNIS ANTETOKOUNMPO AT
THAT PLUS 360 RANGE.
>> I LIKE THAT, SAM.
I LIKE THAT.
LET ME GET IN THE COMMENTS.
I WANT TO SEE WHO THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
I GOT YOU -- ACTUALLY, I SEE
WHAT YOU DID THERE, SHAQ.
HE HAS KEVIN DURANT.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
MY BOY SAYS EMBIID HAS BEEN
UNSTOPPABLE.
EMBIID HAS DEFINITELY BEEN
THEY CAN'T STOP HIM DOING
ANYTHING AND HE IMPROVED HIS
SHOOTING A LOT BECOMING MORE
DANGEROUS TO OTHER -- NO,
BECOMING MORE DANGEROUS TO OTHER
TEAMS.
I THINK THAT HE'S AGREEING WITH
YOU, SAM.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT GIANNIS
ANTETOKOUNMPO.
I'LL JUMP IN HERE.
I THINK, ME PERSONALLY, I THINK
STEPH CURRY IS GOING TO WIN THE
MVP.
BUT I DON'T THINK THAT I WANT TO
BET ON STEPH CURRY RIGHT NOW TO
WIN THE MVP.
I'LL BE HONEST RIGHT NOW, SAM.
I SEE JOHN MORANT DOWN THERE.
JOHN MORANT MIGHT BE WORTH A
SPRINKLE.
HE'S BEEN PLAYING GOOD
BASKETBALL.
ANOTHER NAME, SAM, THAT I SEE
DOWN THERE, KEVIN DURANT.
NOW, HERE ME OUT.
A RUN AWAY.
A RUN AWAY IS ALL KEVIN DURANT
IS.
I MEAN, WE WERE JUST TALKING
ABOUT HIM LAST MONTH.
STEPH CURRY AND KEVIN DURANT ARE
THE TWO FAVORITES.
TAKE A SPRINKLE.
WE KNOW WHAT BASKETBALL TEAMS DO
AFTER THE ALL STAR BREAK.
THEY TURN IT ON.
K.D. COULD BE A RUN AWAY.
A RUN AWAY FROM BEING MVP.
SO I THINK IF I'M TAKING A
SPRINKLE, I MIGHT SPRINKLE ON
K.D. AND WE'LL SEE IF WE GET
RICH, SAM.
WE'LL SEE IF WE GET RICH.
NOW LET'S TALK ROOKIE OF THE
YEAR.
CUNNINGHAM JUST DID AN INTERVIEW
WITH BLEACHER REPORT AND HE
CALLED HIMSELF -- HE CLAIMED HE
WAS THE BEST ROOKIE.
HERE'S THE GRAPHIC RIGHT HERE
WHERE HE SAID HE FELT LIKE HE'S
THE BEST ROOKIE.
HE SAID IT, SAM.
SO DO YOU AGREE?
WHAT IS YOUR TAKE ON ROOKIE OF
THE YEAR?
>> YEAH.
I DON'T.
I -- I WAS NOT GOING TO BE JUST
TAKE THE CHALK WITH MVP.
I WILL DO IT FOR ROOKIE OF THE
YEAR.
I LIKE EVAN HERE.
HIS NUMBERS ARE FANTASTIC.
THE THING I LIKE MOST IS THE
TEAM HE'S ON.
THE CAVS HAVE BEEN THE DARLING
OF THE NBA.
AND I THINK THEY LIKE TO REWARD
THOSE TEAMS.
THEY LIKE TO LEAVE AWARD SEASON
SAYING THE CAVS GOT SOMETHING
AND THEY'RE HAVING AN AMAZING
YEAR.
UNLESS THEY COMPLETELY FALL
APART AND FALL OUT OF THE
PLAYOFF PICTURE AND ALL THAT
STUFF WHICH I DON'T THINK THAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN.
THAT'S NOT HAPPENING.
I THINK THIS IS MOBLEY'S AWARD
TO LOSE.
HOW IS HE GOING TO MAKE THAT
JUMP WHEN THEY'RE PLAYING NEAR
THE SAME LEVEL?
I JUST DON'T SEE IT.
SO I LIKE MOBLEY.
>> YEAH.
I'M RIGHT THERE WITH YOU, SAM.
I THINK THIS IS A RUNAWAY FOR
HIM.
THEY WILL BE IN PLAYOFF
CONTENTION.
HE'S A KEY PIECE OF THEIR TEAM
SO I CAN SEE HIM RUNNING AWAY
WITH THAT.
GET IT NOW.
IT MIGHT GO UP SOONER OR LATER.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS, SAM.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS.
HERE WE GO.
GIDDY AT PLUS 1900 IS AN AMAZING
SPOT FOR A BET OFFICIALLY,
COOPER.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
YOU WERE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I GOT ONE MORE IN ME.
I GOT ONE MORE HOODIE IN ME,
SAM.
I SEE MOBLEY EASILY WITH A LOT
OF EXCLAMATION MARKS.
SO SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
FINALLY, SAM, LET'S SEE THE ODDS
TO WIN IT ALL.
LET'S SEE THE ODDS TO WIN IT
ALL.
AND WHEN THE ODDS GET UP THERE,
SAM, WHAT ARE YOU THINKING?
WHAT ARE YOU THINKING HERE?
WHICH WAY ARE YOU LEANING?
WHO ARE YOU PUTTING YOUR MONEY
ON?
>> WELL, I'M GLAD WE'RE DOING
THIS AT THE END OF THE SHOW
BECAUSE I'M PROBABLY GOING TO
LOSE THE AUDIENCE HERE, IF I
HAVEN'T ALREADY TO BE HONEST.
I REALLY LIKE THE JAZZ AT 12-1.
THE THING THAT STANDS OUT TO ME
MOST IS THIS IS JUST A VALUE
PLAY TO ME.
LIKE THEY HAVE AROUND THE SAME
ODDS AS THE LOS ANGELES LAKERS
WHO ARE NOT GOOD RIGHT NOW
STRAIGHT UP.
YOU HAVE A JAZZ TEAM THAT'S A
NUMBER ONE OFFENSE IN THE SPORT.
THEY'RE THIRD AND OVERALL NET
RATING.
TO ME, THEY REMIND ME A LOT OF
THE BUCKS FROM LAST YEAR.
THREE, FOUR YEARS IN A ROW WHERE
THE BUCKS WERE THE BEST TEAM IN
THE REGULAR SEASON.
THEY HAD DISAPPOINTING PLAYOFF
FINISHES.
EVERYONE WROTE THEM OFF, CAN'T
WIN IT ALL.
THAT CREATES VALUE ON THEM LAST
YEAR.
THEY DID END UP WINNING THE
TITLE.
I FEEL THAT SAME WAY FOR THE
JAZZ THIS YEAR.
I THINK THEY SHOULD BE PRICED
AROUND WHERE THE JAZZ ARE.
THIS TEAM IS GOOD.
THEY ARE SO DEEP.
THEY HAVE SO MUCH TALENT.
I THINK THE JAZZ RECOGNIZE THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT YEAR FOR THEM SO
I WOULDN'T BE SURPRISED TO SEE
THEM MAKE A MOVE AT THE TRADE
DEADLINE.
IF YOU ARE ABLE TO SEE THEM AT
THE SAME PRICE AS THE LAKERS, I
THINK IT'S A GREAT VALUE.
>> I LIKE THAT, SAM.
I DON'T DISLIKE YOUR BET.
MY THING IS IT IS JUST HARD FOR
ME TO PUT MONEY ON THE JAZZ
BECAUSE MY THING IS DO THEY HAVE
THE SUPERSTAR POWER TO WIN IN
THE PLAYOFFS?
WE KNOW IN THE PLAYOFFS IT IS A
LOST OF ADJUSTMENTS, AND THAT'S
WHEN THE SUPERSTARS COME OUT TO
PLAY.
DO THE JAZZ HAVE THE SUPERSTARS
POWER?
I DON'T KNOW.
I HAVE BEEN SAYING IT SINCE THE
BEGINNING, AND THAT'S THE GOLDEN
STATE WARRIORS.
THEY WENT BACK UP, SAM.
THEY WENT BACK UP.
THEY'RE NOT THE FAVORITES
ANYMORE.
THEY'RE NOT EVEN CLOSE TO BEING
THE FAVORITES.
THEY'RE SECOND, BUT A FAR WAYS
AWAY.
LET'S NOT TALK WARRIORS.
I WANT TO SPRINKLE IT AROUND.
CAN WE PULL THE GRAPHIC BACK UP?
BECAUSE I WANT TO SHOW THEM A
TEAM THAT I'M TALKING ABOUT
THAT'S ON THAT GRAPHIC.
AND THERE IT IS.
YOU GUYS SEE THE PHOENIX SUNS
SITTING AT PLUS 800?
THEY WERE IN THE CHAMPIONSHIP
LAST YEAR.
THEY'RE THE BEST TEAM IN
BASKETBALL, AND THEY'RE SITTING
AT PLUS 800.
I DON'T SEE THIS BEING A BAD
BET, SAM.
I DON'T SEE THAT BEING A BAD
BET, AND I MIGHT SPRINKLE MY
MONEY ON THE PHOENIX SUNS TO WIN
THE CHAMPIONSHIP.
BUT, SAM, I THINK -- I THINK
THAT'S IT, BROTHER.
IT'S BEEN FUN.
IT'S BEEN FUN, BUT I THINK THAT
THAT'S IT.
THANK YOU GUYS FOR TAPPING INTO
THE GROUP CHAT PRESENTED BY
FANDUEL.
REMEMBER WHAT YOU LEARNED TODAY.
THE INDIANA PACERS VERSUS THE
GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS.
THREE BY TWO IS A LOCK.
THE SUNS MONEY LINE ALSO IS A
LOCK.
GET ON FANDUEL AND TELL OUR BR
BETTING SAME GAME PARLAY AND
PRAY FOR SAM AND HIS JAZZ
FUTURE.
WE'LL BE BACK NEXT THURSDAY
GIVING OUT MORE HOODIES, MORE
JERSEYS AND MORE LOCKS.
IF YOU WANT A HOODIE TODAY, WE
WILL DM YOU.
MAYBE SAM MIGHT.
SAM MIGHT.
I TOLD YOU GUYS HE'S THE TOP OF
THE SOCIAL TEAM.
BUT I WON'T DM YOU.
BR BETTING WILL DM YOU, SO DON'T
BE ALARMED.
ALONGSIDE MY MAN SAM RICHMOND,
WE ARE LEAVING THE GROUP CHAT.
PEACE.